C
BEY , QUOTE,HE
NU
RUZELE
UKRAINE.
MATTIVERS  FRONT IN
GEORGIA WITH
>> D AET ACROSS
FROM A CHURCES A BAR C
GRL.A HOLY PLACE OF SORTS FOR AD
LAGGER AND A CONVERSATION.
ANTHE BAOW RUSSIAN
SA HE'D ONE PA
NV AORE LATELYELLO, OING
THDAYS
AGO.
>> T'S MORE RUSSIANS
NG
>> WHY ARE PEOPLE LEAVING?
ARED.>> WT A HALFEN
CHE HERE, BUT ONE STOOT.FT RUSS
HUSBD JUST A F
THE WAR BEGAN.>> YOU CLDTAORE R.
>> YESIT
ADDITIONALER.
I JUST HAD T
>> THE 3YEEN
A MEMBERF RUSSIA'S OPPOSITION
SHE SA.R OF CR
THIS IS HER BEING ARRESTED
2016 WHILE SHE WAS WORKING AS AN
INDEPENDENT POLL WG IN HER
MEN
P-PUTHORISED HER OF VAGUE ELECN
DETENTION UNTIL VOTING ENDED
T  THE FINAL
STRAW. NO LONGER LIVE IN
IA. GIAS
EVER T WHAT SIDE SHE'S
ON.
>> I IT
SIGNAL AS MUCH AI  THE UKRAI FL.
>> A PUBLIC SHOWSUPPOR
TCSSESA, UKRAINE
T PUDED BYS IN
ATHY FOR
WHAT UKRAINIAN
IT'S NOT JUS
SENTIMENT.
ANTI-PUTIN.
IT SAYS E THAN WELCOMEAGRE
A WAR CRIMINAL ANDPE
OFEALEAR HOW THES OF
ANOTHER SIGN AT A OPAWAY SAYS I,
EVIL.REE WITH T
STEASE DO NOT COME
MANY RUSSIANS IN FEE
PROTESTS WHERE AN EFFIF S BU
NDS THEY'RSO
NONETHELESS.
OVERY AFTER WE
RINKING OUT OF
EMBLAZONED WH UKRAINE'S
RECENTLY WAOFRIVER
>>NOT NICE KNOWING THAT ED.
YOU'RE THEK AT BARS THAT THE VA
MAJORITY OGIANS HAVE BEEN
T
THEY'RE GRATEFUL TO  I
THERE.AI'LL BE HERE FOOK
BUT I'M NOER
ANYTIME SOON. SD US SHE'S
ACO SPEAK
RUSSIAN HERE IA EVEN
IASAYS SHE USUALLY START
COMMUNICATING WITH PEOPLE IN
ENGLISH  WILL ACTULYPERMISSIONK
RUSSIAN,OM
YES.METIMES PEOP SAY NO.
ACCORDING TO THE LATEST
INFORMATION FROM GEORGIA'S
GOVERNMENTF N 30,000 RUSSIAN